please join me Sunday night for a look
at how another summit three decades ago
changed the world three days in Moscow
covers President Ronald Reagan's efforts
to reach a nuclear agreement with Soviet
Soviet President Soviet leader Mikhail
Gorbachev based on my new book three
days in Moscow here's a preview when I
came in in 1982 Reagan was still in full
throated denunciation of the Soviet
Union he was still very much playing the
cold warrior what I'm describing now is
a plan and a hope for the long term the
march of freedom and democracy which
will leave Marxism Leninism on the ash
heap of history few even among his
allies shared his belief that the Cold
War was winnable there was a huge
argument within the administration
people in the Defense Department and the
CIA both thought the Soviet unit was
there that was to time we were here
there there that's life got a lot the
American public seemed to agree nearly
three-quarters favored a nuclear freeze
by the United States and Soviet Union I
urge you to beware the temptation of
pride the temptation of blindly
declaring yourselves above it all that
sparked Reagan's most forceful criticism
ever of the Soviet Union to ignore the
facts of history and the aggressive
impulses of an evil empire to simply
call the arms race a giant
misunderstanding and thereby remove
yourself from the struggle between right
and wrong and good and evil I was at the
speech where he talked about the evil
empire and the focus of evil in the
modern world it was stunning even by
Reagan standards that was pretty blunt
and pretty raw three days in Moscow they
abused Sunday night 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Time